breaking news now and uk health
officials say everyone over the age of
50 as well as health workers and those
most at risk of complications from cobit
19 will be offered booster jabs in the
autumn it comes as cases of coronavirus
continue to surge across the uk with an
increase of almost a third in the past
week joining me now is professor adam
finn member of the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization uh thanks
so much for joining me professor finn so
uh
the recommendation uh as i think i'm
writing saying uh a couple of months ago
was for those over 65 to get the booster
shot clearly the government's enacting
those over 50. talk us through why uh
suddenly we're increasing the number of
people that that need to get this
booster
uh yes good afternoon wilfred uh the
there's always been clear that we were
going to need a booster program and that
age was going to be the
critical factor
in determining
uh exactly who should be targeted for
these vaccines but it wasn't entirely
clear
earlier in the
in the summer
where the line should be drawn
but i think the evidence we've now seen
makes it clear in terms of what we're
seeing at the moment that we should go
for a very straightforward simple and uh
clear program of offering both influenza
and cobit boosters to everyone over the
age of 50 as well as people who for
other reasons are at high risk of
serious illness because what these
vaccines can do is to keep you out of
hospital
keep the nhs going
and minimize the chance of disruption
when we get to the depths of the winter
and and again just talk us through why
it's so crucial to do
uh as we approach winter as opposed to
as you know you're saying already these
cases have been shooting up of of late
why will it get worse still in the
winter
yeah it's always hard to predict the
future and i guess we while we knew that
we might be seeing a wave at this time
we certainly had no
strong expectation of that happening
this virus continues to catch us out and
do the unexpected but if you look back
over the last two winters we have seen
uh significant waves in the winter time
and indeed we do see that every year in
normal times with all of the other
respiratory viruses that that circulate
around so particularly december january
february
sometimes into march
very difficult periods for the nhs every
year with lots of people particularly
old people being admitted to hospital
with respiratory infections so uh
although we can't guarantee it uh it's
certainly a serious risk that this will
happen again this winter and we want to
protect against that happening as best
we can and just to clarify so the the
flu the influenza vaccine is is that the
same recommendation only those over 50
exactly right so in in the past flu
vaccines have been offered to the over
65's again it's a an illness that is
particularly a problem for uh for the
elderly um last year we extended that
down to the age of 50 um and we're doing
exactly the same thing this year um we
really do need to protect the health
service as best we can and the the risks
of serious illness do go up with age
certainly by the time you get to my age
in the early 60s you are an at-risk
person so people like me and our my age
group definitely need to be uh immunized
as well
in terms of why we're only going for the
over 50s and not everyone again or all
adults again is that because of
a good reason because younger people
don't need it and then the variants now
aren't too threatening or a bad reason
because we don't have the supply or we
don't have perhaps the ability to
distribute it quickly enough
no it is a good reason
we are seeing very little serious
illness now in healthy younger people
both adults and children
and i think that's a combination of the
vaccinations they've many of them have
received as well as the fact of course
that they've
most people have now actually had
coveted at least once uh in addition to
being vaccinated so there's a lot of
immunity out there in the population
and we're not seeing significant
problems with serious illness now these
vaccines are not very reliable at
preventing infection as many of us have
discovered in recent weeks and months
but they do reliably protect against
serious illness so we need to target
them at the people who are at risk of
that serious illness and that is the
older people not the younger ones and
just finally uh professor whilst we've
got you here a comment on the latest
numbers i think we saw that go up by a
third uh this week again is this a sort
of case of they're worrying we've got to
keep an eye on it but given that
hospitalizations and deaths aren't
following suit to the same extent that
that we don't need to be too worried
well i think it is worrying i mean it's
an enormous number of infections and
it's certainly being very disruptive a
lot of people in my clinical research
team and laboratory are off sick with
kovid at the moment and i'm sure
everyone who's listening to this is
being affected by one way or another
so it's not a trivial problem by any
manner of means uh and in addition as
you uh just heard in your previous
report we're seeing significant
pressures on the health service right
now which is very uncharacteristic for
this time of year so i think people
should recognize that this is not
trivial
it does need
to be thought about and any efforts that
people can make to try and reduce the
transmission of infection
will help bring that peak down professor
finn thanks so much for joining me much
appreciated